how does someone really know they're a
writer maybe they just like the idea
of being a writer the identity of it no
it's a good question
as always um i've found
with actors as well people who i've come
in contact with
that some people like to play the role
and others like to actually do the work
and so there's a uh you can see because
when it starts getting difficult
those who want to play the role go um
this is hard and then
it becomes like well do you really want
to do this and you know writers
i always say writers write you know
there's writers are a special breed
you know what i mean um i know if it's
hard to explain
but you're the one up at two o'clock in
the morning with
passion and you can't to use a double
negative not
right you know it's it's something that
you
that's in your blood it's in your dna to
be a creative person like that
so those people you know i say i used to
work in a restaurant as a waiter and
there were some
people who wanted to be actors and
writers as well no i'm working on the
thing and they never finished something
that's also another indication where you
can't see it through
where this person who writes yeah it's
it's
there's a lot of fear involved because
it may be crap you know you may not
you may not be at a level where you want
to be but you have to get through that
to get to the other side to master
anything
um martial arts whatever it is that
you're studying
so a lot of the people wanted to be
actors
you know liked the you know i'm brooding
yeah but
you know i'm an actor you know wearing
the leather jacket and you said well
you're going on auditions
well no are you taking classes well no
you know i have a good look
okay that'll get only so far you know
what i mean so i think um
you can some people may try try writing
like say oh i think i'd like to write a
screenplay which is fantastic
it might not be the um
you know maybe novel writing is better
suited or maybe both of them are not you
know it takes a big commitment so
i think you find your way but for me
since i was 11 i knew that this was kind
of my calling you know making movies and
things when we were we were shooting
films short movies at 11 years old
i i knew you know because i nothing
would would stray me from that
so um yeah i think it's uh
i think you've either find out that it's
not what you really are passionate about
or you early on you know it's your
passion
and nothing's going to stop you from it
so i think that's what
what designates you know a writer for
the long haul
and the test of when things are
uncomfortable and
looks like it's not going to happen yeah
i always say failure is
is a test to see how badly you want it
you know
and and this life of a writer is filled
with rejection
failure and criticism and it's not going
to go away even when you start working
in fact the stakes i think are even
higher because then there's
money involved and contracts and
pressure like
i have to work under a deadline
and that was the first thing that was
difficult for me when i started working
professionally
is that you're supposed to be creative
under a deadline and how can you do that
and some when you're working on your
specs
it's open-ended right you well i won't
work today or i'll go to the beach
and when it becomes your job it's the
job with any responsibility like a job
has to do you clock in and you know your
clock in time might be
you know three in the afternoon as long
as you get those pages done
you know at a certain time so um
you